there is one little silver lining here
which is the Biden Administration was
just asked to clarify
its stance on the draft
you know the libs are pushing to draft
women though that remains controversial
as of now the men have to
sign up for the draft but what about the
trans women
what about you know the men they're men
but then now they identify as women and
the Biden Administration insists that
they really are women and the Biden
Administration insists that these people
who are totally women really need to be
allowed to serve in the military
so okay but what about the draft
women are not drafted at the moment
to the men who identify as women have to
sign up for the draft
because the answer to that question is
going to tell us what they really
believe about transgenderism and I am
somewhat relieved to say
that the Biden Administration knows that
these people are not actually women
bind Administration says this is the new
guidance on requirements for Selective
Service U.S citizens are immigrants who
are born male and change to their gender
to female are still required to register
individuals who are born female and
change their gender to male are not
required to register
so there it is now you might say this is
hypocritical this is incoherent sure but
as La Roche Foucault points out
hypocrisy is the tribute Vice pays to
Virtue and the Biden Administration is
admitting here for all their clap trap
talk about the transgender women are
women and we need all they all these
hulking men in leotards need to be able
to swim on the girls swim team and they
need to be able to use the bathroom in
the locker rooms with the girls and but
for all that crap when it comes down to
it when it comes down to brass tacks
they they do know
that these men are not actually women
they know it
they're just deceiving everybody and
they're they're trying to even deceive
themselves I think also Biden is
realizing he's gone too far
he looks at the polls and yes the the
rule of the liberal establishment does
not rely
entirely or even largely on public
opinion but public opinion still plays
some role the opinion of the people
still has influence over the kind of
government that we're going to have at
least to some degree and I think Biden's
looking at it he says man we've gone way
too far
I'm very very unpopular I'm underwater
on every single issue and so now Biden
is really focusing in as we had we're
less than a month out from the midterm
elections
he's focusing in
on two words let me start off with two
words
made in America
made in America
two words that's right
I'm gonna I've just got one word For You
Madonna is a lesbian I have just got
three words my name is Michael Knowles
and this is the Michael Knowles show
I've got two words made in America
everyone is focusing in on Biden's
senility and his inability to count or
speak which is very funny Biden gaps are
always very very funny
to me the more interesting thing about
this clip though
is what it seems to Signal about Biden's
political views
or at the very least of the political
views of the administration that wrote
that line
made in America
is this hold on is this the same Joe
Biden who said a rising China is great
for everybody is this the same Joe Biden
of the same Democratic party that's all
in favor of shipping our jobs overseas
and not protecting American
manufacturing and regularly mocking
actually
the people who've worked in American
manufacturing said well they just got to
learn to code
yeah those people whose jobs were
shipping overseas or shipping down to
Mexico
yeah they're just dumb idiots you know
they should have they should have gotten
a degree in coding or journalism they
should get a blue check mark on Twitter
they're dumb idiots you know forget
about made in America who cares make
everything overseas and then it'll be a
little bit cheaper and that'll somehow
even out that'll somehow
is that is that the same guy
because it sounds to me like when Joe
Biden says we've got a made in America
agenda
sounds like he's he's kind of channeling
the America first movement or the make
America great again movement it sounds
to me like he's kind of channeling
Donald Trump
Donald Trump is the first major
politician
certainly presidential candidate in many
years who put a focus on
bringing manufacturing back to America
in either party in either party
and that what's most interesting to me
about this clip
is that Joe Biden realizes if he wants
to be more popular going into the
midterm elections and going into
the General in 2024
he's got to be more like Trump
it's an admission and it's it's why I
tell you do not lose heart do not think
that all your views of your your
pro-life your you support
marriage as it's been understood for all
of human history you you like your
borders and your American flag and your
apple pie and your hot dogs on the
fourth of July and that's you like
Christopher Columbus and you don't think
that 65 year old pop singers should just
become lesbians all of a sudden and you
know you're but your views they're
outdated no one shares your views you're
an old foggy you're an artifact they're
just waiting for you to die I'm just
telling you
your views are much more popular your
views are not dead the thing about the
tradition is that it's not some old
dusty dead thing from the past it's the
most vibrant thing that we have in the
present because it is endured so much
struggle so so many new fashions through
history and it is endured because it is
strong and your views are strong and
it's it's not just me telling you that
the president of the United States in
honest moments the Democratic party in
their honest moments they know that
you're right too and they know that
those views resonate as well stick by
them the rest of the show is continuing
now you do not want to miss it okay I'm
bringing on the man that I'm playing
fantasy football this week that would be
Jake crane of crane and Company I made
the huge mistake of allowing my producer
Ben Davies to choose my fantasy football
team which is why I think I'm in dead
last right now so uh for some reason I'm
still making another bet on whether I'll
win this week I'm assuming I'll probably
lose this one last time I lost I had to
electrocute myself on camera who knows
what we'll do this time be sure to head
on over there the member block be begins
right now
[Music]
[Music]